we also ask you refrain from heckling
the comedians during the performance and
now we are proud to present your host
for the evening please put your eggs
together for the very funny and talented
mr hearts cube
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up [ __ ] how you guys
doing
let's uh go on some dates and let's uh
watch people go on dates who's excited
about that
it's gonna be a good time what's up dude
thanks for signing up man
this guy lives in his van
uh my name is hans kim i am an asian
stand-up comedian i also am single
currently
so you know
there's some my way you know after you
guys are done having fun over there no
just kidding i'm not uh desperate and
weird uh my name is hans kim uh this is
a great dating show this is a dating
show that's revolutionizing dating in
austin everyone's doing it differently
ever since we started the show a month
ago
i am excited to do this so how it works
is that people put their names in the
bucket please do that the more names the
better and then
pull randomly two names out and then you
go on a date for one minute and then
after a minute uh you we interview you
we talk to you we make jokes we uh we
have a good time
uh and that's how the show works are you
guys ready to meet our guests
our guest tonight
is a very very funny comedian from
florida she's been on the secret show
with brian redband a whole bunch you're
not a very funny heather shaw
[Applause]
hey yeah i'm doing pretty good how are
you doing i'm gay
she's gay
really gays in here
oh i was going to leave okay cool two
gays
are they on a date with each other oh
yeah well we could be weird it's my
sister okay hey it's heather's sister uh
so uh how's uh what's the last date
you've been on oh boy i don't even know
um
the last date i was on probably new
year's new year's date on years yeah you
got the kiss they got the kiss i got the
new year's kiss nice man it sucks it's
funny i got a kiss too on new year's
who from a woman oh did you know where
yeah no not i know her now was it random
like what do you mean where are you yeah
i met her at a comedy show so
well you were kissing a dude yeah i was
kissing someone too good for you dude oh
yeah look at us knuckles listen on new
year's eve anyways maybe someone will
kiss tonight that we could watch dude i
hope you guys sign up for this [ __ ]
please tell me somebody like put their
name
wait is there a timer going
cool
all right 40 more seconds is there a
next button that i can just hit
next
that's fine
what do you like to do for fun
um i cook what do you do
i like to eat
okay
how much time do we have on the timer
um do you play sports no
cool
i play basketball obviously oh okay
end time
get up for gargi and zach you might both
be dying alone that was rough
[Music]
you guys know each other though right
oh good perfect i don't feel bad
you love to cook he loves to eat
come on
what are you guys gonna do just gorge
just
he's gonna be uh he's gonna be way way
heavier than he is now
what's the uh what's the biggest uh
accomplishment that you've done in your
life so far
this date zach
besides the state
pick up the mic and let's hear your
answer
whoa
in real life or in your dreams
in my real life hell yeah dude that's
awesome are you just talking about the
date you've been on or a real marathon
i don't know which one was more future
damn
the marathon was way like 100 times
worse thank you for that ringing
endorsement of the show
better than a marathon other people
dating
uh so zach and gargey you both signed up
in the same bucket were you expecting to
go uh with like just some random people
yeah
i honestly was down for whatever
where are you guys from
um i'm from india
hello
welcome
welcome
what state is that
south of here yeah they're in the
midwest
i think i've heard of it and zach where
are you from india oh just uh pick up
the mic
baltimore baltimore
cleanest biggest city in america it is
yeah no heroin there that's the india of
america
that's the reading capital americans
yeah
yeah the what the reading capital the
reading our benches say that in
baltimore reading capital the reading
capital to read all the charges
we read here mostly street signs
and criminal documents yeah
that was a rough day i'm not gonna lie
you uh you asked what's your best pickup
line you said something about a cucumber
or something yeah if you were a
vegetable you'd be a cucumber
why
because it's a cute
cucumber a cute cucumber cucumber yeah
that's about what
i know that was on the spot
i just like that that was like the first
thing you said on if you were on an
actual first date and you sat down and
then you were just like you if you were
a vegetable
it's
well that's because he asked the
question what's your favorite pickup
line
oh you did i missed that part i'm sorry
i'm an idiot
a pretty important part of this yeah i
was like i thought you just out of the
gate were like if you were a vegetable
this is not good she really does love to
cook yeah right yeah exactly
i was worried
so are you a vegan because you're from
india
no
yes i'm from india but not the vegan
part oh thank god all right well i'm
right here
she's a vegan i'm a lesbian i have to be
she doesn't eat meat
should have seen the sausage party
before this is puking everywhere
uh so you uh you like to have fun
what do you what do you do for fun
around here zach
yeah eat food
he's food
personality character damn man
so how do you feel watching heather eat
right now is that right i'm literally
looking at it he's doing his favorite
thing in the world right now i was
trying to figure out what was in the
sandwich it's a it's a vegan cuban it's
really good it says mushrooms you should
try the food it's really good yeah creek
in the crave freaking outside
they should call the food truck creek
and crave you know like yeah all right
okay this is what it's called is it
called freaking crave yeah oh i'm an
idiot
she heather is not from baltimore she's
not a reader
where's india
she's from india that's why she's vegan
yeah uh so uh gargi is that your name
cargi
uh no jargy no it's gargy
okay would you like to go on a date with
some random person and then zach maybe
you could go on a date with some random
yeah later
sure because you can get you can get a
guy up here with attack right
sorry if you're a woman i suggest you
sign up
uh how are there
typical women
always saying they're
women
okay i'm guessing that's a woman so
let's get this oh that's also a woman
geez a lot of women you guys just gave
it up on bumble huh
this hinge just disappointed you so
let's see gargey go on a date with cody
[ __ ] him up gergie
are you sure he's not bi too he might be
with that bandana look at that
that bisexual bandana it's bye bandann
greggy you've already had a warm up this
one should go better
uh cody is a consummate professional and
let's see you guys go on a date
i'm probably the only person here to
make you feel less awkward
cool yeah how are you you're welcome oh
i'm very good thank you
see
uh so uh you come here often
it's my first time here oh do you enjoy
it are you having a good time
i might you might in a bit
i've come here a couple times i've
enjoyed myself it's been it's been
entertaining i i don't think dating in
the real world is feasible so i just
come here and pretend okay that's cool
yeah well good luck
yeah what about you
um i'm i'm just visiting austin for a
few days oh fun yeah do you go back to
india or are you here in the states more
um i
i teach in kentucky oh okay
really yeah what do you teach political
science oh awesome i was almost a
teacher but then i realized how much
they make and got a job doing video game
stuff so oh that's cool yeah they don't
pay they don't make much i'm very sorry
a lot of my family are teachers yeah
end time
give it up for guardian cody
cody really showing up uh zach over
there with this stellar date has to do
with comfort
he's just constantly asking questions
he's comfortable no matter what happens
he's in the zone he's got the bandana on
the hair is not in his eyes
sweat isn't dripping into he can see
everything he's he's ready for this he's
an ass he's a is a dating athlete yeah
he could be far too much credit hans
you're welcome well you didn't i mean
you didn't landers are not that good
but good what is your first impressions
gargie of this handsome gentleman cody
over here
what if she was just like hard pass
keep the conversation going that was
nice
very very good talker
most people tell me i talk too much so
that's nice thank you i got you
you can keep the conversation going and
going and
it just never ends
you uh you said that you're not dating
in the real world so this is how you
date uh but i saw that you brought uh
someone with you tonight is that not a
date not really just friends
oh hello do you want it to be a date
he's like please shut up
have you signed up
don't perceive you should definitely
sign up if cody's going to do it you got
to show him up show him how a real day
goes
where do you teach in kentucky just out
of curiosity political science nowhere
oh where university of kentucky is
you're a professor
that's so cool
they're like the lebron james of
teachers
so what's something that you uh would
assume about cody's political science
do you think he's vaccinated
[Music]
i thought he had to be to do this
right
it was a very strict vaccination policy
zach can you pass me a mask
no for the record i'm fully vaccinated
and once boosted nice me too yes i hope
i'm done with it tired of being stabbed
yeah okay
except by
yeah well you just signed up for the men
straight men bucket so you won't be
stuck in the tie
dude you and zach i feel would just
start [ __ ] on stage
it would definitely be the top because
you can't stop talking
um do you think that it's uh feasible
that uh
the date went well um no
you're just visiting how long are you
visiting for i leave tomorrow
oh nice
bummer your heart broken cody
i'm sorry not really but oh nice to meet
you cool you too
cody you [ __ ] up right there uh i'm
crushed and devastated i don't know how
i'll sleep tonight just lie better
sleepy time t
so what have you uh what have you done
in austin so far you've been here a
couple days a week
um
[Music]
so ate a bunch of food since zach likes
to eat
um
the gay bars that was yesterday um
[Music]
the mexi art museum went to that today
that was fun oh yeah mexican art museum
the gay bar is good here
this is fine fine that's not good better
than lexington they have uh whoa you
hear that austin yeah
we're beating out lexington kentucky
we've hit the big time this is like san
francisco compared to lexington
louisville
home of the uh birds right they're
cardinals or something
yeah i think that's a mascot
my girlfriend goes to law school at uk
so if you see her say hi oh really yeah
isn't that weird that's so cool i just
made that up no i'm kidding no those are
your hands
what did you say after the gay bar you
uh
museum or something museum of mexican
art you know that's actually where cody
got his bandana from yeah
beautiful bandana thanks
what uh what made you decide on the
bandana over like a hairband or like a
ponytail
well at first i didn't have enough hair
for a ponytail
shoes i wish
um
and then
it was just i had the hair but i had the
headband the bandana thing and i made it
work
nice
so what kind of comments do you get
walking down the street like where's
your bird scooter you [ __ ] hippie
a lot of people do call me a hippie most
people compliment me i have i'm not
wearing them i normally have round large
blue hippie glasses so they go with the
headband quite well
so uh what do you think about hippies
would you ever
be in a long-term relationship with a
hippie
is that to me or her no to her okay
a political science professor
[Laughter]
what
i'm down for anything really
anything how would you describe hippies
to your political science students in a
political science context
the hippie movement of the united states
in the 70s
hairy indignant
poop e
i will say i teach world politics so
anything but the us is what i specialize
in good for you oh good that's a good
move yes appreciate it lately our
politics have been kind of crazy
so uh what is their favorite thing about
world politics right now
my classes are pretty easy so that's
probably their favorite part
um
what's hers favorite yeah yeah about the
world choosing students oh
i don't know i teach a lot of war and
conflict classes so there's really not a
lot of favorite
aspects of that but nice yeah
i think cody's have a favorite war
yeah cody hates war if you couldn't tell
it's very true it's a hippie that's
right yes
i just would probably let someone beat
the [ __ ] out of me and just cry about it
if he was in charge of the world you
wouldn't have a job
because there'd be no more wars so good
thing he's not in charge
i don't know about that if there were no
wars i think you'd want me to be in
charge if that's the exchange we've just
made but then she doesn't have a job in
political would you sacrifice your job
for world peace yes okay
put me in charge
well i'm thinking long term i'm thinking
about gargi's uh
mortgage payments that she needs to make
um if i'm in charge i'll make you
cutting degree of education
what is your favorite war
uh we'll save the war on drugs because
drugs won the war on drugs
his favorite war is the one that sent
millions of black people
mine would have to be world war ii but i
guess you could say that the jews kind
of got the raw end of the stick there
what happened it was rough
it's uh it's highly debated there's no
clear answers but
what about the jews
they they time her up
they made a lot of money she's like get
me out of here
all right give it up for gargi and cody
let's get uh one of these real live
ladies up here
we're gonna get zach up here to go on a
date with some random lucky man hell
yeah that's my favorite one of you
straight guys they just start making
ready shima
is coming up here on a date going on a
date with a man oh whoa i thought it was
hacking okay
hell yeah shima chris mueller hell yeah
chris mueller where are you at
christopher mueller chris mueller looks
cute
looks like cuties i think this might be
a thing look at him come on
this is a couple look at this huh give
it up for chris mueller and shima
they both drinking beer this is a good
start here we go
so we just go yeah we're on a date right
now oh hey how's your day uh how's my
date it just started no you're dating oh
damn
i went on a hike to bulls creek with my
mom actually so it was a mom daughter
type day actually is your mom here too
she signed up in the bucket so hopefully
she gets a good date
that's really cool i mean i figured
might as well get the whole experience
and everything like that for sure how's
about your day that's awesome i just
hung out at latch keys latch keys yeah
so what is latchkeys because i'm
originally from austin but i live in
detroit and i'm visiting for a couple
weeks um it's a bar but um yeah it's
like a cool hangout spot um detroit i'm
actually from or i lived in michigan for
a little bit did you really yeah bay
city right
right there yeah
yeah yeah so of course like detroit's
like right here basically yeah so we're
from the bay city city right here boom
smack dab
born and raised or no i'm from wisconsin
you know [ __ ] i'm a big loser right
now dude
oh nice cool oh you brought your own
koozie i'm from wisconsin alcoholic dude
so explain this end time
give it up for chris mueller and shima
come on that was good huh take notes
going on a date that was a rapid fire
you guys were going at it too good
chemistry stallion two whitish people i
mean it's only michigan was the current
chemistry right
you're both drinking beer and you're
white what yeah
thank god what else you need
chris is definitely white shima looks a
little mexican shima has a name that's i
always get the mexican she's not mexican
is not really mexican are you white i am
white but that's not it's nice that's
not all time
you got half of it right cool that's
that's more than one
half white and then a quarter black and
a quarter japanese that's dope
basically that's not from china that's
cool
did you say kung fu panda thank her
basically she's like thank you for
[ __ ] a black man
did you [ __ ] a black guy no you're
japanese she's black and asian so i mean
oh you [ __ ] white guy oh you [ __ ]
the wife
that's not that special
i mean it's standard right if you're in
america might as well live the american
dream it's like
getting vanilla ice cream
is that you bourbon those are some sick
burgers i know i'm a lesbian
[Laughter]
i keep hearing them i'm like who the
[ __ ] doing that yeah
uh shima so uh how many dates have you
been on it so far in 2022
technically the first one i mean that's
awesome i mean i mean
i
no
offense
seeing somebody but at the same time we
haven't really went on a date since 2022
so is it all virtual
huh is it all virtual no it's been
physical
so you haven't gone on a date
well we have but
she's dating someone so it's not like
they go out on a date you guys have just
been [ __ ] yeah well he has three kids
no jesus christ
he scared the lesbian
lesbian heard there were kids involved
they very rarely have to deal with
children
um so cody oh here she is she came back
thank god as soon as i was done okay
so you're [ __ ] a dude with three kids
cody no you oh
you're [ __ ] a dude with three kids
and you've never dude
oh chris
uh they brought your koozie dude i'm
sorry about the pack i'm packers fans oh
yeah it's all good it's kind of a relief
i don't got to worry about going back
home for the super bowl so yeah
that's nice that's what we want did they
just lose today he lost to the 49ers
last week last week
that's uh
the last time he watched that koozie was
the last time no they won the uh that's
funny i am that color because like it's
supposed to look like the wisconsin's
license plate in the winter time so it
doesn't look dirty you know what i'm
talking about like no i didn't know did
i say wiscanson weird
is this just what you say to everyone
what i'm sorry all my [ __ ]
is dirty all my objects look like worn
down and dirty but it's because it's
supposed to resemble the license plate
in wisconsin you gotta make up lies dude
we're both banners chris uh where do you
see yourself in five years relationship
wise
you want to get married you want to have
three kids and then divorce and start
banging
a single lady
never go on dates
i don't know man i'm trying to do this
whole [ __ ] career but yeah kids would
be sick what career what's that career
uh going on dates being a comedian oh
really oh [ __ ] yeah dude good luck
it's all fun shima have you ever dated a
comedian before um
i've dated technically an improviser oh
god
we were holy [ __ ] i mean i didn't improv
before too so i mean i wrote in a sketch
show i really gotta go not even close to
a comedian no no not at all
although i've talked about doing
stand-up but i can't in bed with him
yeah right oh i made her laugh that's
what they all say good job chris thanks
point it out every time it happens
um so uh
you uh was it fun like was he like good
at improvising was he like a good
conversationalist did he like
make you like
i'm a tree and then you have to like put
stuff on it pretty much i mean
everything was a joke i guess at the end
of the day but i mean hey
sounds awful i know to be honest even
the relationship
i mean you got to learn when to turn it
off chris are you uh good at separating
your comedy life from your profession or
a personal life
yeah i think so
okay let's say uh you guys are
an old married couple and you guys are
you know uh
on on a date
and uh chris is like he keeps trying to
be a comedian and it's like
it's like a thing and you guys are just
like just on a date and let's just
pretend like it's happening and action
i got like two years left but i'm
telling you i'm gonna make it soon i'm
telling you how many more minutes do we
have left
well we're old so we have like i don't
know like a hundred minutes left before
we die oh sweetie i mean i've been with
you this long so i might as well just i
can't believe your brain is still around
this is awesome i mean she's asian and
black
what are you questioning
i'm the white one so i mean i'm going to
deteriorate quicker than this at this
point
yeah yeah i'm making a big yeah i got
this new gig
uh next sunday i'm on this hans kim
dating show you know why didn't i hear
about this until now actually it's where
we first met you remember that yeah i do
remember who else are you going to be
dating
are you going to be on with hans
uh yeah yeah i'm going to be dating hans
yeah 50 years of comedy i'm finally
making it big you are making i'm on a
date let's get them on stage wow i'm
proud of you thank you you make me happy
right now i'm so happy i married you
[ __ ]
and seen give it up for chris and shima
going on an imaginary day together
so uh
i don't see a future with you guys not
me neither
we only connected on the michigan bit we
i wish my hands can [ __ ] do all that
great two hands for texas baby
two hands everything's bigger in texas
especially the pregnancy bellies
[Laughter]
can't abort it either you gotta carry it
to terms it keeps growing
all right how has austin changed since
you've been here oh a lot it's metal and
glass and a lot of hipsters i mean it
was always hipsters but i mean what were
you guys building with before
limestone limestone
does anyone know what's up
um so that's cool was it a good place to
date before austin yeah
uh don't ask me ask other single ladies
out here i have no idea it was a
long-term relationship and so that took
my time nice yeah i mean i guess
long term that's where you get all the
good stuff
from being long term yeah like uh
connection and intimacy and all that
yeah
up until like year five and then it kind
of dwindles i guess
well anyways chris
has your dating history been as
depressing as shema's i hope not um no
not really my girlfriend's still up in
new england but i totally like you know
do whatever you want like i can't give
you any time but we're still like
together i'm just like if you got to do
something go do it but
it's a great conversation yeah hey uh do
whatever you want
it's like yeah i'm gonna
take off
yeah
so we're like together but you know i
just told her like i'm [ __ ] doing
this so don't waste your time with me if
you don't want so she was like noted
yeah
yeah she's like i've been doing that the
whole time
we just met
we're in new england
um
new hampshire
new hampshire let's call her up see what
she's up to
no i'm just kidding
[Laughter]
that's fine you don't have to
uh so you went from wisconsin to new
hampshire
uh no i was in
newport rhode island i was in the coast
guard i was stationed up there and then
now i'm out and i live here
nice yeah it's a real lateral move to go
from wisconsin to rhode island i did not
yeah i didn't choose to but
that's where they put me so he was in
the armed forces that's technically a
veteran well i was in the coast guard so
don't get your [ __ ]
yeah that's part of the thing
it's fancy yeah you guys got a robot in
uh iron man
coast guard robot really yeah the first
one or the second one uh so uh have you
ever dated a veteran before of the armed
forces no
but he just counted himself not a
veteran so i don't know he's humble you
know
do you go to war do you shoot any kids
and dogs no we're in the coast guard we
save lives oh right yeah so the opposite
right
kinda
yeah yeah i don't know the last time a
coast guard member killed somebody
that'd be i'm pretty sure they got a
bunch of people just got fired they're
not doing their job
um what did you uh what did you do
um i started out search and rescue and
then um when i was in newport i was on a
buoy tender it was pretty sick it's like
does anyone even know what a buoy is
yeah it floats in the yeah we're not
[ __ ] idiots what is a buoy
some people don't know what a buoy is
shut it cody
i'm kidding i mean i've heard of a bad
tender but a buoy tender it was sick
yeah are you like this this strain of
buoy is like it'll make you high
buoy tenders so funny
chris
stop criticizing my comedy
keep going dude
don't ask the audience why they're
laughing i wasn't asking i was asking
that one guy uh so bowie tender you had
one buoy you were in charge of for
multiple buoys what a life
hundreds of buoys thank you for serving
i told
you now you are not military if you can
tend a buoy he can tend a woman yeah
true
or a man
yeah exactly we gotta get a lot of
crustaceans off those buoys so i guess
yeah yeah it's a hard life
did you eat any of them
um no is there a lot of seafood in the
coast guard
i guess so yeah
sometimes
[ __ ] phenomenal cooks you guys are
right there might as well go fishing
yeah
so did you rescue anyone
um not personally with my hands i was on
like
haste one time on xbox
yeah my buddy was dead in xbox and i
like drug him away he had like two
seconds left before you like restarted i
almost got him yeah were you driving the
hell or were you flying the helicopter
were you uh in charge of the wench no i
was uh boston's mate so like i was on
boats and [ __ ] you were uh i feel like
i'm watching the history channel
this is the kind of stuff that i'm
interested in
anyways
so much boring technical awesome [ __ ]
with chris shima what do you do for work
uh real estate in detroit and also work
for an art school because you know gotta
work two jobs real estate and
teaching no i wish i was that impressive
like
political science over here but uh no i
just i'm a staff member at the art
school nice yeah
so you're like the coast guard of the
school
i guess
because i have a lot in common i save
lives and what can i say
save lives what do you do do you do the
paperwork or i work for facilities
campus safety and events so a lot of
covid recently just to do contact
tracing and then
i don't know facility worthy stuff so
making sure yeah things get snow plowed
and
the amazing awesome things that people
don't think about when they think about
art school yeah you're in charge of the
nuts and bolts
i'm not really in charge of it i just
kind of coordinate the stuff i just tell
people kind of where they need to be
when they need to be like a facility
tender
you can attend the buoys you can attend
the facility yeah so uh done more for
your country than i have thank you thank
you for real it's good to know that
honestly at this point
yeah the all the great people coming out
of art school
you could prevent the next
hitler went to art school didn't he he
failed yeah he failed yeah that's crazy
so just think of that next time you're
at yours yeah don't fail the wrong
[ __ ] student this time i'm not the
teacher i don't have any responsibility
just make sure the road is plowed you
should just pass everybody in art school
you made it here okay good we don't want
another hitler just [ __ ]
good job to me
just give them what am i talking about
give them a nice art school experience
uh so yeah i mean uh any any final words
for this wonderful couple
um good luck
that was a good date thank you
i wanna i wanna date with someone two
people that are single and live here
yeah like i'm out of town my mom is one
of them because she for sure is single
and lives here so i mean who likes milfs
hey mom
not white white milk see there
are we off yeah maybe you could get a
make her a gilf go make out in the
bathroom or something
no no thank everybody give it up for
chris and shima
they went on a date together
oh my god they're already making out
that was so cool oh my god they're uh
there they are
all right the next date is dean
stanfield and cathy d
boy cathy d
deeney is a charmer everybody's gonna
get wet in here including me here he
comes
he's strutting up here with his cowboy
hat look at this sexy man
oh baby deeney you about to be in for a
gift look at this beautiful woman
sit over there what's that drink
where's
this your better light too oh look i'm
telling you this guy's a [ __ ] charmer
oh
come on
that's so cute thank you ma'am
howdy there all right go on a date
together and it's starting now
[Music]
it's not a good way to start a date
that's okay that's okay
but i have a mullet so like where did we
where did we think we were going do you
want some more wine can i get you
another wine how do we
sure
can i have another wine for the lady
please
they're in the back
how are you what's your name kathy kathy
dean stanfield it's nice to meet you
dean yeah nice name
thank you oh i appreciate that i wasn't
fishing but you know it's nice when you
catch them
so uh what do you do what do you do for
a living what do you do for a living i
am a nurse manager nurse manager oh cool
nurses are the best um
my grandma really wants me to find a
nurse
my mom my mom and my grandma both were
like you should find you a nurse
because they make the most money
no
it makes more money than a comedian i
think more money than a teacher too oh
wow oh teachers don't make anything
that's so sad yeah it is very sad the
state's going sad i don't like that
what's your favorite color
red red oh that's okay cool well we i
picked the perfect setting for us see
the top of my crocs are red that's
pretty hot
don't look at my crocs no first date
don't look at my crocs
that's like a second date thing i do
like older women yeah with three kids
oh no
that's the kids probably about all the
same age as you are oh
and time give it up for dean and
kathy d
so
you have three kids your daughter is uh
dating a man with three kids
yeah
yeah there's a pattern there yeah
she's really into family
thank you so much
cheers shot of wine she just chugs it
again
started the date off with a swig
you uh you got the party started
dean the party animal come on you have
uh
dean is this the first time you've been
around anybody black or japanese whoa
whoa
heather where did that come from well
it's a rodeo guy
dean is white
yeah i've dated i've dated uh a girl
from jamaica oh hell yeah
her name is
she was just a white girl she was one of
those whites and i can't remember her
name but we did it for like three weeks
it was a magical three weeks it was it
was fantastic we had sex in a cabana
we're not talking about other dates on
another date
she was a good woman she was awesome
she's very nice to me
[Music]
not awesome enough to remember her name
i know i wish i could her boobs i can
tell i can tell you exactly
centimeter to nipple ratio on a pad of
paper where her boobs are but i cannot
remember her name that's impressive
thank you thank you i pay attention i'm
a detailed guy i'm a detail-oriented guy
she's not the ones that excites her name
you know
he's a boobs guy i'm a boob guy
uh uh have you ever been on a date with
a uh
redneck person before
oh god we're just thinking about it
you know cause it's been a long time
it's been a while
shima will be happy to know that
no i have not okay no okay cool so what
kind of experience can you provide uh
you know kathy dee cause she's never
been on a date with a redneck before a
redneck i could uh i could serve you
some of the sausage that i made okay
that sounds bad i just i did well no
sausage but i did make deer sausage on
this stage like an hour and a half ago
and i can i can go out there and get
some and i can
and then you can have some of that
that's pretty redneck would you would
you eat would you have some of dean's
sausage
probably not the beer
yeah probably not the beer it's a little
risque yeah yeah it's a little i've had
it once oh venison yeah okay once and i
didn't like the taste yeah some people
this isn't going to work out
i eat a lot of deer i'm not going to lie
i eat a lot of deer
dean's uh mostly
i did shoot the deer yeah he's savage he
shoots tears thank you thank you it's
pretty neat that i mean i wouldn't shoot
it but
you want to come watch me shoot a deer
i'll watch it it's pretty cool yeah yeah
it's it's definitely a lot more damning
than you would think yeah it's a lot
more like oh that's happening oh yeah i
killed a deer killed a deer man didn't
have to but did it anyways
so you would be the accessory to the
crime um are you uh
yeah are you pretty uh into animal
rights
well yeah i mean i like deer but i eat
meat
hell yeah i i will say i won't kill it
myself to eat it oh good
yeah
but if somebody else will do it for me i
will
certainly eat it certainly i mean it's
dead anyways yeah yeah you got it you
don't want to have to see it
yeah
anyways heather is uh
she's just challenging not to leave
again i know right no i'm fine i don't
care about animals yeah i mean we're all
contradicting ourselves aren't you a
you're not a vegetarian are you vegan oh
that's like a super vegetarian is it
yeah those are the top tier have you
ever been vegetarian or vegan i tried it
for i think
maybe one to two months okay and it was
still actually i was a pescetarian for
two months that means you've got two
months eat fish [ __ ] baby [ __ ]
hey i'm not gonna lie to you this is not
the first date that i've been on that
i'm worried it's so easy remember it's a
good 80s mullet yeah i really work hard
on it oh those are the days
right you weren't even born in the 80s
heather shaw she could be 75 we have no
idea
she won't show anybody her driver's
license
what's the name of the guy that
achy achy
um that is so osiris he's bill right see
i get i get a little upset
do you know what travis tritt is though
billy gay cyrus yeah do you know travis
tripp yeah okay yeah i think i think i'm
trying more for a travis trick because
billy ray cyrus went crazy and got rid
of his guns so i don't like him anymore
sometimes more of like a travis trick
kind of thing going on
yeah who would he give them to the
school
shooters a pretty good one
where'd they go
thank you
thanks so much
kathy have you ever shot a gun before
yes at a school no
have you been near somebody that shot a
gun no wow
that's crazy like the separation you
know that's why i said i i'd watch you
shoot a deer yeah
but that's about it but that's about it
but after you watched me shoot the deer
would you be like
i'll shoot a deer now
do you think you would take any further
you just want to see i think it out
like what if i shot one and then there
was another one running across the field
i'm like
there's your meal there's your milk you
can chew one i'm gonna eat i don't know
what you're doing and then at that point
would you do you think you could after
you saw me do it
no yeah
it's interesting
it's hard sometimes yeah you look out
there and you're like it's so beautiful
i don't want to kill it and put a bullet
in it yeah well everyone's a vegan until
the zombies
until the zombie apocalypse i will just
i'll just die
i don't care
i don't think so i think you're gonna
get hungry enough and you're like
i could eat a rabbit yeah well [ __ ]
rabbits yeah what what i get it they're
weird they're horny
don't they rape everything they're
basically oh no what is your view of the
world i read it in a highlights magazine
once
bunnies rape no dude little rape well
most animals technically rape but right
not really what
i mean it's not like
you can't just like ask for consent when
you got a fluffy tail and also what is
being hungry
nothing that cute rapes look at all the
weird people
that's there's no hot dudes that are
maybe there are
okay i don't know that much about it i
read a life magazine one time get with a
lesbian yeah it was highlights
yeah what about sienna may
siename is an instagram star that's
accused of why do you know this has
gotten this has been a weird date this
has been i think so yeah
what are you doing bunny rape yeah what
are you drinking
yeah how did we get this one this one
that's the one i'm a bunny
they call her thumper yeah
right yeah
she's eating pancakes
these are these are mushroom cubans
they're really good they're really good
you like mushrooms i don't know just
making something that's already good
vegan yeah
well i have to i'm lesbian it was either
you know be vegan or buy a subaru oh
that makes sense
you got a subaru we're not doing this
we're on a date right now
lady
are you from texas are you from texas
um oklahoma actually oh man
how does that happen
what do you mean how does that happen
how have you never shot a gun and you've
lived here forever
yeah
so you fix up people who got shot yeah
have you ever done that actually kids
i'm with
kids
you're pregnant
the children of gangs how many kids get
shot you said yeah when you said you
sowed somebody up and got shot how many
kids are getting shot around you
what do you live in colleen what the
hell
a guess is you might have fixed up my
buddy oh
he was like nine he got shot in a
drive-by there in a [ __ ] colleen
texas three times with a nine millimeter
he did not go down he was the coolest
kid in school until the [ __ ] day we
graduated actually where i'm from
my dad was in the military
this has been a fun day
thank you so much for this this is it
was got weird there for a second we
really wrapped this thing up with a bow
oh
that was perfect so everyone goes out
there shoots guns then they come to you
after they get shot and you fix them up
yes kids
kids
america baby
give us our guns
i need to make that i love you clear
no she only fixes kids you twerp oh talk
to my date like that one more time see
what happens
i got you
he's got your back
what a southern gentleman he's gonna
shoot heather and then you're gonna have
to
you're gonna have to fix her up
yeah just kidding i'm a kid she's got
the organs of a child yeah really
they're failing
um so
uh where have you lived in texas colleen
austin colleen and austin colleen in
austin colleen and austin what a guest
what a what a great guest
my dad was in the military so i lived in
germany
oh
what is that nice
what is germany yeah
the country i don't know
the country jeremy my dad was stationed
there cool
you would think that it doesn't make
sense but she gets the hottest babes
it makes no sense
i think it's because they don't like
getting treated well i think that's what
it is
surprise surprise women like to get
talked down to i want to disappoint my
dad but i want to bring a black guy home
you know it's like that kind of thing
did you hear that it was funny i said
women they're like oh i'll date her
because i want to disappoint my dad but
i don't want to date a black guy oh
that's true yeah
and you're equally as disappointing as a
black guy but not as much yeah
me too i feel like
i get that a lot yeah yeah i get that
kind of high vibes i'd be like oh thank
god she's not getting penetrated that
hard
we're not getting shot as much but
there's a lot more meth labs and
explosions
and sometimes fort hood hits us with
grenades and they don't even [ __ ] say
anything about it what are those things
that go up in the air mortar rounds
we've gotten hit by more mortar rounds
in florence texas you know what they do
they bring a piece of paper and they go
oops
we did that because you know that's the
largest military training base
in the
what is it germany the world
it doesn't surprise me that
it doesn't surprise me that dean grew up
in a shooting range for the u.s army
two of the ponds that are on my dad's
property were made by mortar rounds
two ponds
what do you call them uh we call them
tanks
stock tanks yeah yeah my dad was just i
came back i'd i was like 10 and we had
one pawn
and then i i left for five years because
of cps and then when i got back
child protective services
cool it's cool yeah
i'm over it it's fine and then i got
back and then
i got back and then i was like oh my god
is that a do we have two tanks now my
dad was like yeah mortar round hit back
out there and so we got a new tank the
u.s military shut your mouth you little
just kidding
after they took me after the guy
i'm just trying to make it funny again
you know that's
okay well that's the good thing about
living in florence
yep that's florence for you that's
florence that's hey listen
uh it's a good place
on the map
huh
oh small places
yeah you blink you'll miss it
i'm always blinking
the uh military people got killed going
back and forth
they'd come to uh yeah they'd come to
austin get [ __ ] up and then they drive
all the way back and then they were fine
because there's like a lot of lights but
then once you turn off of 35 going down
195 to killeen it's literally just
florence and so it's just like dark and
then there's like lots of curves and
stuff so there's like four turns that
have killed
like way more soldiers than anybody in
iraq has holy [ __ ] yeah so they
closed that
road although they didn't really close
it but they closed it to the military
they weren't allowed to just the
military so if you were in if you were
in the military like you don't [ __ ]
drive on this road dude
i'm just drinking that's pretty much
what they said don't drive on it you're
getting trouble yeah
cool that's what they're doing in
afghanistan they're just building windy
roads yeah right yeah
that was that
anybody been raped
no with the bunny [ __ ] this lesbian oh
the bunny yeah
hey give it up for dean and kathy d love
you guys
they're gonna make shima another sibling
shima you got a little redneck coming
i didn't understand that hey
he's a very round man
uh bernard white going on a date with
zach bernie boy where you at
he left
bernard white
he's not here
[ __ ] man i'm not having a good date
anyone want to go on a date did you want
to go on a date tonight
hell yeah leah let's go
is that lee i hope leo
i think she wanted to go did you want to
go home
she'll go on a date hell yeah
what's your name what's your name
bernard white what
merle
oh laurel give it up for laurel
and uh any man want to go on a date
and yeah
this guy will go on a date what's your
name
kai
[Music]
give it up for these people
laurel and kylin that sounds like a fun
indie rom-com
one minute and go ahead and go okay
how's it going great how's your day been
that's been actually really good
really good i um
i went thrifting this morning
and then my friend bought me lunch
and then now i'm here
how about you
i probably shouldn't have asked that
question because when you ask a question
the normal response is you want to be
asked that question as well
but i just i had a friend's
high school friend die this morning
and you decided you wanted to go on a
date yes to distract you you got to fill
the void
okay
well i'm sorry
thank you oh man
was that the biggest bomb that's ever
been dropped from the show
it might be the biggest so far
i don't know how to continue with it
from here okay
i'll ask you a question okay
i love weird questions so if you were
ever placed into the witness protection
program what would your new name be
where would you want to live or what
would your profession
be
um
i'd go with like mick loving you the
super bad id
um
i don't know
maybe i'd like
go be like a carpenter in like canada or
something i don't know free healthcare
sounds nice
okay
and time get up for laurel
oh yeah and kai lin
so kylan how did you get your name kai
lin you know that's not his real name no
i'll show you my idea is it really real
yeah sure no you don't have to prove it
okay you just said that you'd get a name
mclovin if you were in the witness
protection program so
it's not really perfect that's right
yeah
maybe you are in the witness protection
program and you chose the name kailyn
and started wearing that beanie my dad's
in the crowd you could ask him where i
got my parents today
everyone wants to bring their parents on
a date yeah
like dad i'm gonna go try to have sex
yeah
can you give me some pointers
what is that what is skyland all about
um what am i all about the name the name
i don't know it's celtic
it means like a forest or like a
building so you don't shave your pubes
oh why did you look at my kyle in down
there
my name is kailyn and i go to kailyn
it depends on the week
depends on the way what are pubes
pubes are things that uh adults get uh
you'll see when you go through puberty
i can't wait
can't wait to start bleeding from my
crotch
laura
how did you come up with that question
the uh the witness protection program
question is that something that you
think about a lot i like crime shows
yeah
hell yeah wait about your friend by the
way oh yeah sucks that was kind of
depressing
well it seems like you're laughing about
it
okay that's what you need
cocaine
what are you high on
uh no that's really really sad uh death
it happens
um
i like how you came on a date to get
over it
and then you immediately brought it up
yeah
i would suggest if you're trying to get
over it
maybe talk about dogs or like the post
office
um so uh
what uh what do you have any pets
did something die what
what are you killing are you killing
your pets and your high school friends
what friday it happened
are you okay girl do you need a hug
she's about to die too i hate to break
it you're gonna come back next week
even more depressed pep died friday and
your friend died today
girl
i'm so sorry
you better watch your luck
i need to watch that i might die
tomorrow yeah don't hang out with me
did the us military drop a mortar on it
was it old though was he shield
no like adult names oh okay you know
damn it that sucks yeah but dogs are
adults at like one year old so i don't
know that's true
he was 35 of dog ears
oh he's 37
i know math i'm a [ __ ]
i guess all asians are [ __ ]
uh kailyn
yeah any anyone or anything die recently
wait how's your dad doing
i'm sure he's doing good i can't see him
out there
i don't know
give us give us a holler gary
mark okay
mark
it was like my kid's gonna be interested
my kid will be successful and then
no
what do you do thailand
uh right now i'm taking classes um in
robotics to political science to work at
tesla
oh you're taking classes to work at
tesla yeah i got like an internship oh
nice they they signed you up for that
yeah nice elon musk is like i need you
to go to school you're dumb as [ __ ]
yeah kinda
he was like i'm building these robots
and i was like that sounds sick and he's
like you know how to do that
no
it's like a
learn go to school
go with a bunch of nerds i bet you're
like the most empathic one there
everyone's just like you know because
you have black fingernails you got a
beanie on well that's just dirt
he doesn't shower he was burying uh
laurel's dog because he's the one that
killed her
yeah that's really dark
got a dark sense of humor
yeah
so you're going to build robots for elon
musk that's number four
the vegan food is really uh cassie it's
it's the beer
up here can we get can we get more beef
can you get me a beer yeah you want a
beer yeah thank you
uh can i have a beer
oh
okay that's your dad
you work for tesla [ __ ] buy your own
beer
laurel uh what do you think about this
tesla employee
he's interesting
that's awesome she knows how to talk to
autistic people
are you into tech
yeah i'm an engineer oh
[ __ ]
do you work for tesla too no okay
you're an engineer with a conscience
do you work or do you have anywhere you
plan to work yeah i'm working right now
yeah this is work this is tedious to her
no i'm kidding
speaking at um for my job
that's cool nice
can you give us an example of like a
joke that you say to warm up the crowd
we don't do jokes it's energy
conferences
so you just
emote energy like
oh thank you
i don't care thanks
uh laurel we found out as an engineer
what kind of engineer i'm a mechanical
engineer by uh schooling this might be a
thing environment
come
go get elon musk to make you a sex robot
yeah
i heard he's working on those
yeah i bet he is
what kind of engineering environmental
hell yeah
i don't know what that means but cool
all right nerds calm down
it's like engineering without any of the
teeth and oil
oh
so what are you what are you doing
you're putting up solar panels and wind
turbines
trying to destroy elon musk's actually
okay yeah this is great
he's burning the world and you're trying
to save it
no elon musk is great we all support him
you haven't you have a tesla whoa damn i
think you just got a sugar mama
kill you
what kind of tesla of course i'm
interested
i'm autistic
um
why you're rich
is it like an airbnb exactly
for cars
got a sleeping bag in there
got you some hot dogs awesome's a hot
popping place to beat people south by
southwest they want to they'll take
anything they'll sleep in the car if
they can
yeah acl weekend you got a car 300 a
night
nice
this guy i mean kailyn
you're working you're going to school
for uh whatever uh robotics
your elon musk told you you're there
you're doing it hopefully how old are
you
22
oh my god you look really old
you gotta start moisturizing or
something bro
you are that's not good for 22. that is
not good
that's not okay
mark get them on something huh
mark is he dead
he might have left yeah he's probably
like [ __ ] my [ __ ] song
i'm kidding i'm just joking i'm the
[ __ ] you're fine
you don't look good though i'll tell you
that i know
yeah you uh you're 22 you're uh
that's awesome dude i mean i can't grow
facial hair like that and i'm 32. i'm a
decade older than you
damn you're the old one yeah
i look like i'm 22 and you look like
you're 32.
yeah you definitely look younger than me
thanks man
yeah
we and uh kathy d and shima
we're all lording over you guys
laurel's actually uh 12 years no i'm
just kidding
13 she's gonna
look like [ __ ]
you
um yeah
but uh laurel uh so you do you go on a
lot of dates with these engineer types
these uh robotics oracle guys
sometimes
and how does it usually end up
with them explaining something and
pulling out their calculator oh god
really
actually if you'll notice the uh helion
god you say bringing out a calculator i
literally i carry a gameboy on me what a
dork
that's like the tiniest screen yeah it's
really small i used to have a game boy
when i was uh 16 years old that was
better than that one
like how are they going backwards in
technology screen is like this big
is it in color at least
yeah it is nice
how does that make you feel he has a
color game boy what is it like to be on
a date with a virgin
what was your first date like in uh high
school or middle school whenever you got
started
i got i actually had my first date in
college whoa
hell yeah you grew
[Music]
that's cool
that's awesome it's like she's all that
i'm still waiting for that to happen to
me
yeah it'll come thanks
i'm swiping yeah all the high school
friends will definitely hit you back up
yeah
they're they're all 32 now
[Music]
so uh so you went on your first date in
college
did you do a keg stand did you uh you
know
go to a toga party
what kind of college date was this
wait so your first day you went on when
you were in college was a 30 year old
guy yeah
so you were 19.
that's his plan he's going to get a
start up and start dating college kids
that's cool where do you meet a 30 year
old
is it
a startup incubator what the [ __ ] is
that
yes
hi chris how you doing
uh that's that's awesome you know you
went on your first date in college
um
is
and getting to know each other publicly
and we
right
okay
let's see these two gentlemen
flirt
with each other
this is gonna set the gay community back
ten years
you dodge a bullet girl
bernard is a very nice man
uh cody of bernard
white boy
okay
uh
for me
oh
that you can't say on here
please don't try to be nice
i think cody you had a better time on
this date with a dude than you did with
the one
yeah you're smiling way more right now
bernard
oh
leah you want to go is a date with uh
one of these gentlemen
bernard you didn't want it
uh if you get another kid i think shiva
might be interested
i will sell
uh any any uh parting words bernard
these are lessons
you're a white
we're going to watch cody go on date
number three on this show cody you're
striking out left and right you better
get to the next
[Music]
one good luck this show was actually
made by a cody so that he could get laid
uh give it up for leah sampson the next
day tested
on the first date
um
absolutely
is
and cody
is
i hope you're a
she therapist do it it's bad for the
cause
uh cody
february
i get three months you can't [ __ ] cuddy
during february
but then he might fall in love
give me your lunch money
is
what did you do cody
what'd you do
you know what's crazy
i was pissed
ocd
and the teacher was like
you guys have that in common
[Music]
rachel
we call him a disney princess what
disney princess does cody
is
if
yo are you kidding me
oh my gosh remember the cinderella with
brandy and then the her prince was like
how cute was that
yeah it was very diverse
can we get a real answer
many black women have you put your
caucasian dick on
he's not a race trainer
yeah you're good for the bloodline
white nationalism you can't joke about
it
cody
uh have you [ __ ] any asian women
how many of my people have you [ __ ]
other times
uh
oh yeah
that's your chance
uh
give it up for cody and leah sampson
that was the show
thank you guys so much for coming out
thanks so much there's no water in there
give it up for heather shaw hey i'm a
[ __ ] you can follow her on uh myspace
myspace
thank you guys so much for coming out
and uh give it up for uh jimmy clifford
and sam kuiper behind the
scene
making the show work there's an open mic
after this please stick around
no banana comes after that there's an
open mic
but give it up for heather shaw bye
everybody for yourselves thank you guys
so much good night
you